what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and a
let's get started
um Also let's try to get to a thousand
likes today 1000 likes on this video hit
that like button okay so today um we're
gonna be talking about old versus young
the reality of dating for men and for
women oh my gosh I have so much to say
about this because of Twitter yes
because of Twitter you know I always
talk to the most intelligent and bright
people on Twitter I have been accused of
hating women because geriatric pregnancy
starts at 35. and this is the
misconception that the red pill says is
it hating women to let them know at 35
you're basically biologically useless to
men
um and maybe we should try to have kids
earlier rather even later and do the
best that we can to achieve that is it
wouldn't that be be good for someone
that's 18 to hear 16 because honestly
guys I'm not really worried about the
the women the older women because I mean
I I think it's tough to deprogram most
of this stuff what I'm thinking about is
the next generation of women that look
at the older women that give them bad
advice maybe this woman accepts her fate
I'm gonna guess she's how old do you
think I think she's she's definitely
pretty I'm gonna say 34. how old do you
think she is you guys all realize that
your sexual market value decays with
time correct I'm not trying to have kids
I don't think that's true I feel like
God we have been coddled so much I get
better that you're estimating your
sexual okay you know what I was thinking
about too the only way women get better
with age is if it is if it's an
unnatural way naturally you look best I
really think women look the best at like
19 18. so you know actually I think
women start to gain weight in college so
it's probably even younger than that but
but the only way that women look better
in their 30s than they did in their 20s
is a as if they were fat in their 20s so
they destroyed their beauty in their 20s
and now they look better but it wasn't
because they were living in a natural
way it's unnatural to eat more calories
right so it's unnatural or they got a
bunch of work done in their 30s and now
they look better but naturally you are
not supposed to look better and so when
women get surgeries and stuff it's
really cheating but the reality is
I don't know I don't know what this
science behind it says but I just think
there is another reason why women age
out faster is because most women don't
even take care of themselves most women
don't go to the gym most women don't
work out most women eat like five times
a day yeah like how I the reality is if
I think if women took better care of
their bodies they might see the
attractiveness last a bit longer yeah
well you could see if you look at
pictures from like 50 years ago the
women in the beaches like they're still
hot oh and oh my gosh the other part was
um
um the the food is a lot more
contaminated now and I heard when you
have kids younger it actually makes you
like look younger in the long run like I
I heard this that like there's some
hormones or something that make you like
look younger I guess value like you said
you said don't don't quote me on that
that's just something I heard right yeah
and you're 33.
44. would you have said something
different would you have said something
different when you were 24. no no no I
would have rated myself maybe a two or
three because being older I feel like I
am in the best shape the best mind and
it's just personal growth so you are you
in better shape than you were in your
20s if the answer is yes then you just
destroyed your beauty from your 20s it
doesn't mean you look like okay you
might technically they always get you on
like a technicality you might
technically look better but your natural
beauty was the best when you were
younger and and that's like the the um
there was like a video going around of
Tate and the funny thing is if you make
the age Gap wider women will agree it's
just like when the age Gap is too small
so there's a video of him saying like
he'd prefer a 19 year old over a 26 year
old because they're like less damaged
and all this and I'm 26 and I'm like
yeah I mean even if even if you could
say you might be less damaged than the
average 26 year old you yourself were
less damaged five years ago another
thing that we kind of ignore is the skin
yeah the skin is literally the one
biggest indicator of beauty that people
don't really think about because it's
kind of like a skin but reality is
there's a reason why babies have better
skin than yeah old people yeah the older
you get the more your skin ages well but
the problem is they get BOTOX yeah but
that's the thing when you see Botox you
know it's both so it kind of like even
gives away your age yeah yeah well and
the other thing is too
it like makes them like shiny like their
their skin it makes it looks plastic
because everything is stretched out the
reality is skin is meant to be able to
stretch and contract yeah but once you
get BOTOX then you kind of well and what
would you look like when because I would
imagine the average chick doesn't make
that much money you're not going to
marry a guy that makes that much money
so what are you gonna look like when it
stops and the funny thing is people get
BOTOX and they don't go to the gym so
think about that so you're keeping your
skin intact but the muscles underneath
are failing yeah so it's
it doesn't make sense you can see a
person's like character by what they
spend money on like it's like what they
care about right because like money is
time in a way and so it's like if she's
spending her money on her her face it
just shows like she's very self-centered
and she cares the most about like Beauty
like it actually I was thinking about
how they used to shame women for caring
too much about beauty because it was
like vanity what is the thing people
that are naturally beautiful don't
really care about beauty yeah so if the
people that struggle so much then it
kind of tells a lot oh my gosh because
okay this is what also irritates me I am
so tired of these women calling me ugly
okay they'll call me ugly when I don't
even know what they look like take off
the 10 pounds of makeup okay take no no
seriously if you're gonna insult
someone's appearance and they do the
same thing to the men they used to call
Kevin Samuels gay they would call him
ugly like I don't want to sleep with you
anyway okay before you do that I want to
see what you look like with no botox for
three months I want to see what you look
like without your waist trainer I want
to see what you look like without all
the you put on your face because
when you think about it it's really
lying because you're telling the guys
that like imagine imagine okay a guy has
a kid with you and this kid comes out
butt ugly because you got all this
plastic surgery done now this man has to
deal with an ugly kid because you got to
be honest about what you looked like or
like imagine you take a girl home from
the bar take her clothes off it's a
waist trainer now you've I mean
obviously he's gonna sleep with you
because he's there but you're there but
but that's a modern day probably and
this is why it's important to meet the
family because
any guy that marries a girl has a kid to
go without actually meeting a family
whatever he gets his own human because
even when you meet the family you can
still end up losing so imagine doing all
that without even meeting the family and
and the other part too is like you can
kind of see what values they were raised
with too based on their on their family
and you can see what they look like he's
thinking of it from a guy's point of
view
do you think women should care about the
guy's family of course yeah I think
everyone should care about whoever they
are picking his family because that that
is the foundation of everything that
sets the pace for everything and you can
even tell how your kids will be raised
by how she was raised okay uh age with
fine wine like fine wine okay good
that's exactly what I said
yeah that's my life saying I like to be
like fine wine get better with age yes
because when I was probably 20 you'd
like to but you don't you won't three I
probably honestly thought I looked hot
but then five years later I'm like I
don't know what I was thinking I really
don't know what I was thinking do you
honestly think you're in better shape
she's in better shape that's not yet
because she's a she's a competitor now
like oh yeah but like the difference is
you understand some man it's not like
the fact that you have an additional
master's degree have a really nice job
and are well traveled those things are
not as important as you just being young
do I think that being Young's important
no to men to some men I'm telling you
that some men see it that way I'm sure
but I mean to me I mean if you try to
guess my age like good luck you know
what I mean I try to take care of myself
so I think honestly it's about one year
level of maturity and two how old do you
actually look because I mean you know no
biology does not care and the women a
lot of women are very delusional to
think that we can't guess their age
I don't think I've never really been off
by more than two years whenever I've
guessed any woman's age never like I've
done it so many times like it's weird
like why would I think she's 23 why I
can't I can't see you because guys they
want to vet you before they like marry
you obviously so if you're in your 30s
like I I've heard that guys don't like
dating women in their 30s too because
they're just in such like a rush to get
married and they can't like take their
time getting to know them where it's
like women in their 20s they at least
know they have a bit more time I think
for guys the perfect age to meet a girl
and quota is like 24 25 in today's
society yeah because then you know
obviously at 24 she's probably not ready
to get married anyways so you could date
her for like three four five years and
probably get married at like 28 29.
yeah I've heard that that 25 to 29
because this is the problem too they're
like well we'll just find a young women
women right but the problem is the
modern woman that's young like there's
also like a high divorce rate when
they're under a certain age too because
like the average chicks feels like she's
missing out I always feel like they've
grown into a different person yeah
God you know they're like oh I've
changed you're supposed to change but
that's that's the other problem when
women lead the relationship too like I
when I hear women say I grew into a
different person like to me that says
the man wasn't leading because I'm sorry
when you date a guy and you really like
him you start like liking the things he
likes you start getting into the stuff
he like you know but when you're leading
then yeah I don't know you just become a
different person they're about 21 but I
wouldn't be able to guess whether
they're 21 or 29 you know what I mean
like they could be younger older you
know just depends on how well you take
care of yourself Rita what do you think
I feel like I've gotten better looking
with age like when I was younger like I
was maybe like attractive but I feel
like now that I I think that Instagram
fuels this delusion
I think that Instagram makes women think
we're we get better looking because even
when you take pictures of yourself it
actually like subtly changes the the
picture so you're not actually seeing
yourself yeah we've just had too many
filters know more about the world and
I've traveled and I've done things that
make me happy like I feel like I look
better because I'm actually being myself
there's kind of a difference for a man
what is being yourself you know
sometimes I can be a should I just
be myself
no it's like it's like what is this
emphasis emphasis on just being who you
are no no no no no no because we all
have negative traits should we just lean
into them and just be who we are now
it's like men will work on themselves
and actually improve women's
self-improvement is just accepting
negative qualities about yourself that's
literally negative our self-improvement
is being confident instead of actually
improving the achievements in his life
are actually the same thing so him
getting the 40 million dollar contract
to start for as a quarterback that makes
him attractive to society it's an
accomplishment and it makes them
attractive to women the fact that he's
big and strong and tall and has a deep
voice that makes him attractive to
society and makes them attractive to
women for women they're two different
things a woman could who cures cancer
doesn't make her husband's penis harder
does that make sense yeah you see so but
it's different so for men the things
that may that give us personal
self-worth are the same things as the
thing that increase our sexual market
value that can also happen to us when we
get older for women it's not the same
for women the things that make men
physiologically attracted to you are
different than the fact that you're
World traveled a good leader a really
good speaker have a master's degree and
no more stuff it's very different
I mean smart men like
what do you mean smart like there's
there's a lot of men out there that
really don't like they they the
intellectual women are more attractive
than what the I think if it's an
intellectual woman that you can have a
conversation with and she brings you
peace then yes but if it's an
intellectual woman whose intent is just
to compete with you the entire time then
the answer would be no that doesn't make
you more attractive the guy the guy that
owns Facebook his girl is pretty
Zuckerberg right oh man we're gonna talk
about Zuck later on oh yeah right she's
not very attractive but he's one of the
richest men in the world exactly
well she's slim
one of the richest man in the world so
you can't really say that and she's
healthy yeah well and a lot of them met
the guys young if Mark was in the dating
market today he would not and then
they'll use freaking what's his face as
an example the they'll they'll go out of
their way to find every example instead
of looking at Hollywood and looking at
the rule instead of looking at rich men
and looking at the rule they'll just be
like oh that exception that exception
yes yes we know there are exceptions can
we talk about the rule before we talk
about exceptions you value yourself what
is it what does it matter so it wouldn't
matter if you want to date a man right
does that make sense it's like if I go
it doesn't matter what my baby men have
spent so much time figuring out what we
want it's like
and we have spent zero time
understanding what men want that's the
that's the crazy thing it says I should
just have that Bugatti until you go to
the until you go to the lot and try to
get the Bugatti and then they're like
wait a second you don't have enough
money in your account objectively so
when you say it doesn't matter what a
man thinks you're correct until you want
a man then it does matter you see what
I'm saying because the relationship is
two people I guess I don't want a man
there you go
no that's that's a boy
a man is the type of guy that
understands that women do get older for
sure
older with somebody a boy is the type of
guy that's like no I need the big tits
figure okay
okay it's not realism you can have both
can I also be a man and recognize all
the value I really don't think maybe
call me crazy I think if you're say men
don't care that much about boobs
boobs all right I know people will be
controversial when looking for a wife
and looking for a wife because when you
look at the women like 50 to 100 years
ago okay they they were all thin and so
even if a girl didn't have like a big
butt it still looked kind of big because
she was so small you know what I mean
guys really aren't that picky they are
not that picky but because we're so fat
you know when you when you have no butt
it looks like a bull like a like a
negative because we're just we're fat
the average it's like before we start
whining that men want women that have
boobs and butt can we get in shape first
I'm sorry I know girls that are flat
flat in both places that have no problem
because they're thin they're thin pretty
face
and the funny thing is they they all
Chase all these outrageous bbls and
stuff but if you look at all the real
men that run Society they don't have any
woman that looks like that it's mostly
entertainers that have those kind of
women I'm so tired of hearing about the
rappers yeah but it's entertainers that
have those kind of women so it fits yeah
so well and the thing is it's like what
entertainers are not real life
and it's like these women will on
guys that like work real jobs because
they're chasing after like and I was
thinking about this like who in college
were the most like popular people it'd
be like the athletes right and I'm
thinking like what utility outside of
college sports would the athletes I
guess good genes like I guess good genes
but I was thinking like in the long run
the engine my mom always told me to go
for the engineers to my mom my mom would
always say go go sit in the engineering
building but when I transferred my
school didn't have engineering I was so
mad and still want someone younger right
so that's the but that's the problem
right that's the reason why I didn't I
bought the car I bought instead of
another car is because the car I bought
was better yeah
for yourself just like you buy
car doesn't talk to you neither does a
younger woman a younger woman doesn't
really oh I know one that talks to me no
I know what that does the trick is
getting her to shut up
obviously I'm dating Michael but I like
older men like even if I wasn't dating
Michael I'd still be dating someone
around the same age because and it's not
even just people I'm dating like my
friends are generally like way older
than me too like for many years it's
been this way like 10 years 5 to 10 even
plus years older than me those are my
like best friends good friends and it's
because yeah like they they know more
than me they've been through more like I
said I just thought of a question do do
you ask a chick if you're dating or
seriously how many men she slept with no
I was just wondering like is there a
number that a girl would tell you and
you'd be like she's lying because every
girl says that
yes and what's the number anything on
the 10. anything under 10 you just
assume she's lying is what number would
you hear him be like she's telling the
truth anything above 10.
would there be any girl you would
believe if she said a number under like
out of let's think of all the hundreds
of women that have been on the show is
there any girl you'd believe if she said
under 10. nope what about the one the
one girl that was a virgin did you meet
her were you here no okay I I'll show
you there's a clip of her though on
fresh and Fit I would believe her so I
can usually tell that she's lying
because she says it's under 10. I just
need to look at her behavior and yeah
she's lying yeah so much from them just
being around them but you know what like
they can come back and say that they
learn from me too I know for a fact you
guys go through this Dynamic but I have
people especially like uh women who are
sort of like anti-red pillar they're
very anti like whatever it is we're
doing and then they'll like and I know
you guys do this on purpose like he says
hey I'm 45 years old and then suddenly
you go yeah I'm 21. and like and then
it's funny and I like how you guys do
this because you'll say that and I know
I know well it does but you let them
Discover it you don't go and put it in
their face so and then you say I'm 21
he's 45 and then somebody like the host
or somebody in the audience or somebody
in the chat will go oh my God you know
like they're shocked about it or
something like that my favorite is when
I tell stories about a girl I went on a
date with in 1996 and she's like that I
can't believe it I can't believe it I
can't believe you're doing that so I'm
like babe you weren't born for five more
years
and that's I don't like how they'll say
a dude is creepy if he dates a younger
woman I do not like that because it's
like okay is she creepy for dating the
old guy but why is it only on him
cheating on me with that like it was
1998. you there's no way
I was talking about I was talking about
a girlfriend I had once in like 2002 and
she's like I can't believe like you were
nine months old
the common one that they say is like
what are you guys gonna talk about like
do you guys have some sort of like
intellectual like conversation like like
you're just like walking around just
drooling not knowing what the hell to
say it I think I I think from like both
of our standpoints like I get way more
hate on it than he does like to him for
a guide
you you're awesome
what's wrong with you what kind of
trauma have you been there and I'm like
that's what nothing men my age suck like
I said I'm sorry oh okay so that's my
that was my next question we joke about
this all the time it's like she looks at
pictures of me when I was her age and
she's like oh God you were cute I would
have dated you and I'm like no the
there's no way you would have dated me
you would have pissed on me if I was on
fire please I'm on fire please just piss
on me so I cannot be on fire anymore she
would not have peed on me I'm telling
you I hate seeing this stupid meme it's
like and and it's guys that do this like
not women do this but it's the meme that
says I wish I could have met you earlier
so I could have loved you longer and
it's like no she was in the hot she was
in the foam Cannon party in Cancun when
she was younger she wouldn't have
anything to do with you man those some
parties are great though
do you think there's any such thing as
too big of an age gap for the kind of
relationship that people want these days
probably but it the reality is yeah it's
a tricky one it's a tricky one so
it's a trick one I'll say yes because
really and truly
um if the men die before women anyway so
if a man is too old he's probably going
to leave and the woman with the
responsibilities yeah well do you know
why I would say yes I would say not no
for modern relationships because the
average marriage is eight years
spend eight years with him anyway what's
what
if she's leaving anyway but but for like
traditional people it's like like a
30-year age Gap I think would be tough
because you're gonna spend the last 30
years of your life alone probably
um you know what's interesting my dad
always told me the number one thing you
should date for is health because you
don't want to spend the second half of
your life alone yeah he told me to break
up with this fat guy once because
he was like why are you dating a guy
that's overweight a lot of women don't
think about if you marry someone for
money and they're unhealthy yeah you're
gonna spend all that money taking care
of that person yeah yeah because one
they're not at some point they're not
going to be able to keep making that
money
I think it was in November December he's
like sending me pictures
are you into older guys or young
youngish older older guys older
um so I'm 21 most of the guys my age
don't really have much experience with
life they're more trying to think okay
the ideal age I would date probably it's
probably 30s yeah the only thing is I
feel like guys in their 30s sometimes
come with an ex-wife or like kids so
that that's the only but if we're gonna
go on like most attracted to I would
probably say like 30 to 35 is ideal
because after 35 I feel like if a guy
hasn't gotten married like I feel like
he's not going to
um he's like I've seen this you know how
this goes seeing a lot of them are in
college and I also want to be with
somebody who I feel like I'm very much
so into more masculine guys and I want
to be with somebody who feels more like
a man to me than a boy still trying to
figure it out what's a man to you in a
sense somebody who has their own
um sense of itself or 21 you're
still figuring it out 45 they're still
figuring it out girl
it's crazy how women can just live in
delusion for longer I feel like if those
girls were two points lower you know
what I mean they're still cute enough
they're gonna get attention from men for
at least another five years it might not
be commitment attention but it'll still
be like I think women get like that when
and especially if they have a body like
that with how fat women are today
they're bikini competitors they're
probably going to get attention from
high value men into their 40s
I'm not saying this to be half like I'm
not saying this as a good thing like a
hundred years ago they wouldn't but with
the if you're telling me the average
chicks five five 170 pounds
you know do you okay do you agree with
this or disagree I think that men it's
like I didn't realize that men a lot of
times it's like body before face do you
think that's true or false
I think I think it depends on the guy
but I've heard that guys look at like
body before they look at face
yeah yeah kind of because that's what we
noticed first yeah well because it would
happen with girls who come on the show
and like I wouldn't think they were cute
but the guys whether or there would be
girls I thought were so pretty and I'd
be like how do you not think she's
pretty but and the guys would be like I
think maybe that might be we can link
that to biology because
as a man those like a woman a woman's
shape her breast her butt everything I
kind of like signals for men yeah it's
kind of like the first thing you would
notice that's why you know what I was
thinking about too women have to put in
no effort into like having a really
great body because if you're just thin
even if you don't have butt in the boobs
like naturally women just have a nice
like shape but a guy has to like lift
for years in order to get to a point
where like women pick him for his body
or women we're just kind of born with it
uh but let me know what you guys think
in the comments
um like the video guys um and let me
know you know am I a big meanie am I
just a big mean woman because I think
that women are hotter at 25 than 35
maybe maybe you know all these women
calling me misogynist or just right but
let me know guys like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel I'll
talk to you next time